so
okay hi everyone we are continuing our
season of design reviews
with
hopefully the tail end of talking about
uh image processing and
video so
this hasn't been updated this hasn't
been updated since we last looked at
this we agreed on a different name here
right
right
you remember that right
it was
frame fitting
it was
shoddy are you here
i'm here you do not hear me
now we do okay this one so yes it's our
last meeting right you're right this is
now
so can we make sure can we make sure for
the next meeting that we have together
that we do have this updated please
yes so we're not looking at no i mean
not i wasn't saying that particularly to
you shoddy i was saying that i see we
have a
geometry and graphics one
so can we make sure that that's updated
please
roger
okay
it can't really happen now because i'm
here and then i need to go away
from this meeting okay then then let's
remove the part of that agenda no no
wait a second let's remove the part of
the agenda that's already been covered i
don't want to see the stuff that we
already went over
okay where are we going next here
we did look at image stitch last time
it was beautiful yes if we could start
from image key points onward
okay
what's the default for image key points
at this point
um it's still sift in our branch but
it's still surf sorry that we had before
sift is a
is a very good possible candidate but
we're not yet switching it or proposing
to switch in this branch i need to run
we need to run benchmarks you know for
sure this is
this has to be the new default
okay how how different i mean you know
key points are randomly chosen anyway so
to speak but i mean how different
is what we get for this
[Music]
the one thing we do want to work on as a
step maybe even in this
version if we can wrap it up is to
document first of all
really examine and then document
properties of different key points like
which one of them are um size invariant
or rotation invariant which one are
const contrast aware which ones are
detected near boundaries of images which
are not and if you know that that would
be really be the key for people to know
which one would be um the right one for
them to choose but you're right all of
them are proposed for
different applications
all of them make sense in different
scenarios just we need to provide
properties for each other so so
i'm wondering
whether it's worth for a while because
these are very mysterious
whether we should have method pages
have we done that for the dimension
reduction methods
i think yes
yeah umap has a method page for instance
okay
that's good yeah you're right i remember
us doing those yes i agree i think
that's highly useful and don't forget
again a thing whenever we do have method
pages or other things like that
to have them mentioned up here right
yes you know that yes parenthetical
yeah i mean well i don't remember this
parenthetical or just different font
okay
all right let's go on here that seems
fine i mean there's nothing no design i
mean it's great
okay image align
improvements which is coming from new
key points as well as whatever was sped
up for the purpose of image stitch
nothing documented
that you need to look at okay
animated image
can now take a video and it will convert
it to an animated
thing in an optimized animated thing in
a notebook is that correct yes we have a
cap on duration we are choosing by
default 12
again up to 12 frames per second
um
the the
if i take hold hold on a second if i
if i were to take from video
oh what's going on here
oh prototype build has that okay this
one i'm not sure if the animated image
bit is important because it was
conflicting with other branches
okay but if i were to take this
and i were to say animated image
of this what's it gonna do
you'll get a five-second animated image
back
what's that what's that that's a gui
problem
that's something in prototype that i
reported yesterday okay all right okay
fine
so what is the five second image is it
is the beginning of it what is it
currently it's the beginning of it i
agree it's not the most useful thing for
um for video but you could do something
like animated image of snippets video of
that video to get potentially something
more useful
but i mean to me just showing the
beginning
without telling anybody what's happening
is pretty weird
you see what i'm saying
we shouldn't we give a message that says
the video is longer we're just showing
the first five seconds
or 12 seconds or whatever it is i like
that yep okay
all right use snippets video for a
summary or something like this yes
but now the snippets video returns
something by default that animated image
can eat
yes
it does okay
it's the right duration
uh no that's also a longer duration the
default is
30 at i think minimum of
duration of the video and 30 seconds
so we're going to waste a bunch of time
snippifying
a big video and then animated image is
going to throw it away that doesn't seem
to me to make a lot of sense
however you can specify the duration in
this video but that's not
[Music]
i wonder
[Music]
if
animated image should by default make a
brief snippets video
which would be
how is animated image fast anyway or
does it is it slow anyway
so you mentioned the image itself is
very fast that what will be the
bottleneck we'll be extracting the
frames from the video
i understand but but if it were just
chopping off the first five seconds or
something is that fast or is that not
fast
i think it's not particularly fast it
took a few seconds for me for the
examples so then what i would like to
suggest
is that the default
if you specify nothing else is that it
does some kind of short snippets video
a five second snippets video i think
that would be more useful carlo
yeah that's fine
okay
and
i think it should probably generate a
message saying it's doing that
so people don't think they got an
animated image image of the whole thing
and then complain could it show up in
progress indicator and not be an actual
message that would be fine
that's a decent idea
we don't have guarantees that the
progress indicator will show up if the
evaluation is less than two seconds
though okay but
we'll know whether it's going to be less
than two seconds
here i bet it isn't going to be to make
a snippets video i bet cannot be done in
less than a few seconds if the original
video is long and large yes i think so
too but if the original video is very
tiny then we then we don't have a
problem it just is
gulped by animated image and all is good
right
i think so
let us experiment with that if okay all
right okay fine sounds good
color separate
it's a very small update um we used to
we used to accept short names for color
channels like r g and b and a lot of
those short names conflicted
we're now adding a new version which is
um accepting things like string red
green blue in the tentative tables down
below
whatever that's fine okay um
i'm a little confused by one thing i
mean when
if you're doing remote sensing for
example
then don't you have named color bands
and and in an image right now
do we have the idea of an association of
of uh
of channels we don't but we talked about
it and i i think once we have that that
would be a perfect way of separating
channels
okay fine
so even now one other addition we should
do to color separate is to accept
indices color separate one two three
why not yeah we don't have it yep we
should do that yeah
okay wait point option for color convert
sounds reasonable
the other two are also just yeah just
documentation update actually okay now
support color as an input oh remove
alpha channel for a for a single color
swatch yeah that'll be useful
correct that's what you're talking about
for a single color directive like rgb
color once i mean so i can say set alpha
channel
of red
comma 0.5 correct
and then remove alpha channel of that
yeah okay that sounds useful
now it sets the lighting option
show image 3d
i understand image 3d would accept the
lighting option
unfortunately not we have some
coordinate differences between graphics
3d and image 3d that had to be sorted
out for lighting to work
and so as a as an easier workaround for
now that is manageable for 13 we are
making this edition in show so that show
of image 3d can take lighting
and then we're going to continue looking
at adding lighting and other graphics 3d
options to image 3d
but so the issue is that the coordinate
system of energy 3d is not the same as
the coordinate system for lighting
yes
look
that problem is going to be insoluble i
think i don't think we're going to want
to have lighting
referencing i think it's going to be
that those kinds of options
will be the equivalent of saying
graphics 3d of image 3d
and then doing lighting which is
effectively what you're doing with show
i think yes yes that show returns
graphics 3d
nobody's ever going to figure out that
you can say show of image 3d to get
lighting
nobody will ever figure it out we could
uh implement graphics 3d of image 3d as
well
that's easier okay we should but also we
should make sure it's properly
documented image in image 3d yes
and then i see so then the idea is to
later on do a coordinate system
switcheroo like we do for for example uh
dates
in list plot and things
to have
to take
the coordinate system of lighting and
interpret it for the image 3d coordinate
system is that correct yes
okay i don't have an opinion about how
horrifying that is or isn't
um
okay text recognized what does that let
us do
um
sorry that's the same same old text
recognize a library upgrade
say i know but what is it
but what's the point
um
nothing specifically is neither design
review yeah i understand that but i'm
asking what does it achieve
uh most of the time it's i don't
remember exactly what we fixed in that
but most of the time it is for us to
stay up to date with libraries so that
the upgrade time is not horrifying and
then bug fixes
all right let's move on
okay
file format properties is this a new
thing yes
why isn't it file format data
why isn't this file format data um
obviously wrong to me
no no strong opinion there this was i
think it's obviously wrong lcc meetings
why was it not concluded that it should
be file format data
oh wait a minute set file format
properties
set file format properties
okay so if i just say
file format properties
oh this was also conflicting in
prototyping okay what build can i look
at it in um this is not in any build can
somebody show it to me on that screen
um i'm sure there is there is however
examples in the page too if you want to
scroll down
okay
and this is now setting a mime type is
that correct no this this one is setting
it well you could set my mime types as
well but mostly i think the one thing
that would be really commonly used by
this function is setting the default
import element rather than anything else
oh this is a mess
this is a mess
this is horrifying
look somebody's gonna set this
in a thousand input notebook and then
they're gonna forget and it's gonna do
one thing and then they're gonna run it
again it's gonna do a different thing
and they're gonna complain
is this really a good idea
oh um
well
i don't think it's a good idea i mean
look i think set options isn't the
greatest of ideas and i never use it
because too often it just messes
everything up
i use said options but not very often
right who was involved in the design
review of this they're not here are they
um sean cheren and etai
i think we need to find them okay i'll
be right
back i i actually don't disagree with
you on this set file format properties i
i don't think there is
we do have the element to specify an
import if you really want to change the
or use a different import element i
think these are both crazy
file names of format list what's this
okay that's
what is the point of this
look the only thing that makes sense to
me is being able to set mime types
somehow and that's only relevant for the
cloud
okay let's get the
relevant people here
okay
okay
all right i'm looking at these other
ones here i thought you guys had already
discussed this in lcc i think you you
were in lcc
yes but i think it's wrong
i mean that's what happens you know we
we
discuss these things then eventually we
implement them and then we look at them
again
and you know usually we get it right
i don't know what the point was here
okay
what has happened with pdf that was
working very beautifully pdf the only
element that wasn't updated in the
previous cycle was vector graphics
now we're adding that
quality wise we are
really close to what we had in legacy
implementation there are some
differences
but overall
the old code was failing for half of the
samples of pdf because it wasn't up to
date to the spec
and now we're succeeding for all of
those right so we can import but what
what aspect of vector graphics were we
not able to do before i don't understand
i mean right now we're able to do the
rather amazing thing of take some random
paper from archive or something in pdf
and import it right yeah and the import
works the the elements that beautifully
work are raster images or plain text
with vector graphics we used to still
fail for half of the pdfs because we
were relying on that old code
now we are porting vector graphics to
the new code
um there are
and for most part we are now going to
develop beyond the
um what we supported before but for what
is coming into 13 we're going to be on
par with the old
with the addition that we're not going
to fail for the half
and um and we are prepped to continue
with that development
so what the graphics language vector
graphics language has evolved
to basically cover i think all the
remaining elements including gradients
and
and patterns and stuff cool
so what's a good example of where i can
get
you know a pdf from the wild
how do i get a a single
archive
i know but it does almost a huge
or whatever i wanted to get something
where i can pull out
a um yeah well let's go
oh let's see
wow
the second paper here
on the list for the new papers is a
topic that i worked on at one point okay
well let's see
let's see whether they have a a um
an image okay let's look on page three
let's see whether we can import that
puppy
okay so what we do
is presumably we say
uh
oh the page graphics that is being added
now is giving you a whole pages as
vector graphics it's not giving you just
individual shapes that you see there
i understand that i understand that i
want to see what it takes
okay so if i say import
so now i'm saying import of this
right
yes
okay
now comma
and then how do i get
okay do i how do i get a particular page
page graphics comma three
or four sorry if that's the page four
well we're about to get the wrong that's
fantastic
okay let's get page four okay i just
wanna see what's involved in pulling out
that image
where is it
where is it
yep that one failed
well at least my bug divining skills are
still intact
how could i have picked one that failed
why do you have a list of elements that
are still on the list to implement and
that's one of them it's probably some
kind of form or something weird in the
back end
okay well just make sure you get a copy
of this
document so you know what to do here we
have thousands of examples but i'll take
this one too
okay
oh look that's probably our colors
okay so this is page six
let's see that's almost certainly a
graphic made by us so let's see if we
can import our own graphics
okay we now have
sean sheeran and etai
okay if it were embedded as some kind of
image then it probably would have been
pulled but it must be
some form or other specific pdf
directive that we just haven't gotten to
yet but it's
it's happening soon
but if i look at this other stuff here
what is this i mean what what is it if i
looked under the hood what what is that
if i say input form of this what is this
most of them are field curves right if
you click click click to get to one of
those characters
yep
oh my gosh
what just happened here what you just
moved one vertex of that field graphics
or fields
you're editing a spline stephen yeah
okay
that's actually that's actually
remarkable that that's possible
okay
well that's a good way actually it's
kind of a good indicator for maybe we
should use that in documents as a way to
highlight
uh okay
a horned figure okay
all right listen we need to talk about
um
we were talking about some
properties
yes
and i'm
actually just just since we're on a roll
here we're almost done with this i want
to hear about mbox do we actually get
the thread thread analysis for mbox
uh yes you'll have to go to this not not
this
that that's a get function page go to
the old tab
format page but it's it performs five
six down
okay
okay so
so how much of threading i mean by the
way
really we actually have this now
yes
wow
has somebody run it on any of my mail
not yet
uh but we have a check in with roger
today at two so i will talk to him oh
this would be fantastic i mean my mail
is i just got one tool that i've been
asking for for five years that just got
developed it's really really nice
and this would be
this would be magnificent to have this
threading analysis
[Music]
okay
very nice what is the thread graph
graph that connects the messages who
replied to which which messages
um no the thread graph is not the
reference i understand but yeah go ahead
reference message id graph
okay
i i think that it's going to need right
because
let's see how does it work any given
message right
okay in a sense the atoms of
male are
senders and receivers
well i guess i guess you're the only
receiver of the mail thread so it is
it is people on the two line or the cc
line or whatever right
so what is happening is a male thread
is effectively
every male message is a hyperedge
in hypergraph
whose whose nodes
are
senders and receiver are our senders or
send or people on the 2 or the cc line
does that make sense the way we have
structured the graph is that every node
is just a message id and then for that
message id you can get all of that
information who sent it who received it
i understand i understand but ultimately
and this is probably something for the
function repository but now
ultimately
you understand that the dual is the
representation of
right so what what
the knitting of the threading of a
thread
happens because
there is a common
member
no i mean it depends i mean there are
multiple different definitions and i
don't know what you used but basically
the the simplest is that there there's
an in reply to
and you know so you have a starting
thread and all the ones point backwards
via and reply to header
but in particular there's a message id
that they all contain
in the in reply to
well transitive well they all contain it
in the references the references
contains a list of every message along
the thread the end reply to is what it
directly responds to
other examples in here
no
however this isn't this is in prototype
build so at least with the example data
file we have in the layout you can try
some of these
okay
well this is an exciting thing to try
for me
um
i've been wanting something like this
for like oh only 20 years
and i'm trying to remember what the
exact use cases are supposed to be i
mean
the main issue is
i remember it it was uh who hasn't
responded to my email
well that one we just have been working
on we just finally have some results for
that
um but i don't know whether they use
this or use something different
not this this has become this has been
added to prototype builds just a week
ago
um
okay well show it to roger i'd love to
see it operating on my stuff
we did some in the when we did graphs
and networks
um like we had a collection of emails
and i know i know i know the enron
corpus
yeah
corporate corpus of enron
right
um but i've seen other things too
you know long after long after
everybody has forgotten about enron as a
company it's email corpus from the
litigation around it will still be out
uh
yeah right
it's um
the but i've seen other analysis too
which sort of indicates what is the
informal leadership structure of a
company as opposed to the formal
leadership strategy and the only one we
know about is enron because that's the
only one where there's a corpus of
emails
the
um
okay
uh
well i'd love to see an example of this
but there isn't one that you can
but i i think i have to play with this
okay but but you're fairly it's a pretty
small inbox in example data if you have
a recent prototype you could
give it a try okay all right where is
that now
scroll down sample data
i mean or another notebook whatever
yeah
i would use conv.mbox.com
ah ah
not what i meant
the next one is convenbox
that's only 13 messages
it'll be a small graph which is
digestible for you know a small example
okay so then what i say is thread graph
of this
okay does this take graph options or not
no
okay
and those are the message ids
okay
all right
and so now
if i want to say okay so let's say i say
thread from list
let's say i want those message ids to be
the
um
so to to be the the from lists from each
of those
right did you understand what i'm asking
let's say i want to thread that with the
thread message id list
okay
so so
but there are many more things there
than there were here
i'm trying to get it so that this graph
i i think they are the same just that
they look longer they it seems longer
because the ids are longer
oh you've you've duplicated the the
senders and the
in the thread from list right there that
seems wrong to me we should fix that
yeah
okay so so just so i understand i mean
the end result here is that i want to
annotate that graph with the from lists
with the no are they send a list so what
are these well the easiest thing to do
is just do a replacement from message id
to
from list just using normal import
elements
okay so hold on so you're saying i can
do this
and just say
from list here
wrap that in uh
well do uh from
not from list
okay so that's every message
so you could wrap that in a double list
and also ask for message id
and that'll give you your mapping
it has to be a double list why
uh otherwise the first element
specification everything after it would
be a sub element that goes to all
elements okay so now i can thread this
there's one other thing that i added for
convenience that you could try well
let's just try this okay so i've
threaded that
oh now i i have to do
maybe three rule
yeah
of that of that thing
yep
okay
okay now i'm getting more than a thread
instead of a comma just do rule
right no i can't do that
no
oh sorry never mind never mind yeah i
can't do that because the import thing
only does that i miss red
okay so now here
i can say instead of vertex automatic i
can say use line 14.
fancy that
great
and it also works great to add tool tips
with like body previews and things
okay
well i hope there'll be good examples of
this and i think you should
get some function repository
things that do
non-trivial
you know that do useful things with
email totally
yeah okay i mean this is very very
helpful it's very i mean if this works
on an industrial scale mbox
this is of high interest
um
good i'm glad we managed to get this
finally i mean
let's see
the quoted content
okay we have the new body content
that's that's been working for a while
right
the new body and coated yes
so for example my meta searcher i don't
think is using that right now and and
one of the things that's very
frustrating is i do a search for
something and i end up getting
you know let's say there's a thread
originally about
you know data about rhinoceroses for
from alpha and then there are 17 replies
which all
quote the original message
right
then i've got
you know copy copy copy copy copy of
that original message
in my search in the results from my
search system
does that make sense
whereas
new body content should allow me to only
get
see okay see the thing that will be good
is and this is something you could
mention to roger
uh
yeah i am
you know the um
is
when we make the index
only do the new body content
and it's probably a good idea i'm not
completely certain i have to think it
through so in other words
if the first message mentioned
rhinoceros
i actually i'm not even sure i mean that
it would be very nice to have some kind
of button that gives it that that
goes down to just
so if you just take quoted content
you're in the risk of losing data but
with new body content you're safe
because everything is basically new body
content worst case scenario they get rid
of the
carrot at the beginning of the line and
you just get more things than you needed
no no no that's no good what i thought
new body content was
was things that were not quoted in
replies yes that's what it is
but you know
the user can ruin the email pretty
easily mail servers can ruin emails
pretty easily but in this case you're
just going to get extra lines maybe most
of the time you're just going to get the
stuff that's new
okay
fine fun fun fun
um
bob on our livestream is saying
doesn't everybody use whatsapp and
snapchat these days
uh not me for sure
no
um
yeah and there's even younger people on
the school who are also responding no
yeah
um despite the fact that
you know
uh people own whatsapp and snapchat
whereas
um
email is one of those things like the
web
so who wants anybody to use that
of course it's different in other
countries some countries there was a
dominant owner of the whole email
infrastructure
different story okay
uh
let's go back to file properties
actually funny how some companies decide
like for instance
ericsson disallows zoom completely
because of security concerns it's
absolutely stopped and blocked
okay where is the use whatsapp
well what business they think they're in
yeah
it's just yeah
all right file format properties
can somebody remind me why this exists
and what the point is
so the primary motivation in in the
beginning was that we wanted to access
options for formats in the system um
right now there's no way to do that
really even internally there's no way to
really generate a list of what options
are supported in each format because the
problem hold on hold on that's the big
here's the big problem
this is not like options that are tied
to a symbol
this is
i know that type of format yeah so it's
not options in that sense okay but
one of the things that i've been
commenting on
is that you know there are things like
the list of musical instruments
supported by sound note that should just
become data repository entries
in other words this isn't data
repository right because you might want
to manipulate this
and what why
how can you
uh using set file format properties
okay what do you really what can you
really do with that
change to default options i know i think
that's absolutely horrifying i think
it's just a formula for getting
horrendous systematic bugs
i mean have you ever actually wanted to
do that
i think you just have asked for it
i think said yeah setting options would
be useful yes
earlier i said setting elements or
default elements
might be useful but not so much but
really setting options is useful
and also tying you know
types
yeah
i think if you wanna like like take
video formats if you always wanna encode
into using a specific codec then you
just set
options and you're good for that session
rather than having to repeat it every
time in every export call
yeah until you forget it the next
session where you only take that one
line and then you've got the wrong codec
okay let's look at these designs okay so
this is an informational thing
right and also don't don't forget that
you know users can add their own
file formats so you know any
how
using the documented method to
add their own format
which is only partly documented right
it's a register file format or something
yep yep register import and register
export and this stuff that i'm working
on is supposed to be a step towards
polishing that up and um
you know delivering it as more of a
system thing
right but i mean when we do need which
we do need more of these
uh i understand user extension
rights i mean
you know that will allow us to have
things in paclets for example to have a
paclet add a file format right but if
you're a power user that's trying to
extend the system this is all the kind
of metadata that you really need access
to
and i know you know many many power
users that are already trying to do this
kind of thing and have hacky workarounds
for it
all right
so
set file format properties well here's a
question for both of you okay
should we
should it be a system property or not
it's a system in a symbol or not
if it's a user extension thing
sort of you know it doesn't have to be a
system symbol
well register importer register import
isn't what what what context is it in
import
export random okay
i mean
it is an interesting general policy
question okay
first question is does it do any harm to
have the i mean let's say register
import
or presumably register file format which
is if we're going with this file format
you know motif
sean i would assume that that will
become when it is systemized it will
become register file format is that true
or not
no because the the import and export
registration looks pretty different
i would say we should look at it i i
wouldn't be so so confident maybe we can
squeeze them into one but sean is right
the amount of stuff the type of stuff
you specify for one is really different
from the other options are completely
different their specifications are
completely different
okay well isn't it kind of weird that we
have one thing called file format
properties
well there's also
these are generic things to the file
format that don't necessarily apply to
import nor export specifically like mime
types right
there's kind of this big overarching
category which is a file format and
there's specific things that are to the
file format and this is related to the
function file format and a lot of the
work that i'm doing in building these
things is integrating them inside the
system so that file format and import
and export is sharing more of the same
stuff
okay
do we know a user example now i mean i i
think the blockchain folk have used some
of this register import
business is that true or what what's it
been used for i could send you a few
stack exchange um links
okay but roughly what kind of formats
what do they do roughly i mean are these
image formats video formats
okay all right fine
well maybe we can put these things in as
experimental functions i'm not convinced
these file format properties things the
other thing i was thinking of if we want
to sort of mull it over one more round
it could go in the same context as
register import and register export is
you know
um
because i you know i think we
i
i'm not sure where they're ultimately
going to live
but it's the same kind of thing in my
mind
give a list of file formats
corresponding to each file extension
what is that doing why isn't that just
in file format properties i don't
understand that it's the inverse
right file format properties you say
what extensions belong to the format csv
with the other one you say
if i have a file named you know blah
which format would that be interpreted
as
if i have a file named i thought that
was
i thought we already had a file format
function that does that
that's for a file that actually exists
this is a string operation that tells
you how it's systematically mapped in
the system
and there's some overlap there file
format has all kinds of heuristics magic
numbers etc
okay so file format you've got a
concrete file
yep
and you can test if it's any of it
either it gives its best guess or you
can ask
is it one of these
specific formats
whereas you know
uh
file names to format list would be you
know star.csv
or better but a better example star.cdf
right what does that
what what will that be imported as and
it gives you sort of all of them right
it's that's right if you go set file
format properties you can make cdf map
to whatever you want it to if you
actually wanted it to be
you know nasa cdf then you can make it
do that then
mime type to format list how do you
specify mime type
just with its file extension
no no string probably right it's a
string image backed image slash jpeg
applications oh okay okay okay like the
usual way of
that's right okay
and we probably have one of the
best systematic mappings in terms of our
formats out there because we really
scrubbed all of the popular lists and
fixed all of their mistakes okay
question
why is there not a mime type interpreter
interpreter of quotes mime type there is
oh
well that's nice
that will
that will return the entity for that
mime type is that correct for that file
format
yeah and they they have it special to do
some cloud things so it's not going to
return the exact same things as our
system would whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
mime type string here okay
and then i say cdf let's say
what the heck is that doing well that's
giving you this the canonical string
right yeah but what i would have wanted
was the
and then and then can i go entity
of what do i do to get the actual entity
associated with this
that's not good how do i do this
uh
well i mean there were presumably other
mime type
interpreters there so
i think you just chose not the one you
actually wanted
okay
i don't see anything else though oh i
thought
there would have been one for uh
uh okay i was mistaken i would have
thought that there would have been like
mime type okay so somebody's got to
unscramble this right they might be mime
type purely just mime type as opposed to
mime type string perhaps
okay
okay so let's go back through this again
okay
you're proposing these functions that
basically take
type
is it just a mime type or is it a name
file
no i see it's an it's a mime type string
right my cameras are used usually in
like http responses to say this payload
is i know right or on an email or
something like that exactly
um
so what this returns as its format list
result is a bunch of strings is that
true not entities just strings correct
well i don't know i mean
roger what do you think i mean maybe
these should just be experimental
functions in the system for right now
i'm not a big fan of putting them in
this other context
fine
that's okay
i want
what i think
and we need some other discussion about
that because i want to sort of add i
have a whole slew of
of sort of advanced user extension
frameworks which are for
open source projects
um all kinds of extension projects to
our system
and this is one of these
this is an old one that we're just
enhancing basically
but the question is where all those guys
live
i hadn't intended for them generally to
be system functions but
right
uh i mean it's okay i think experimental
is it's okay it's not not the end of the
world
all right fine let's do it
okay we had one
completely off topic question which i'll
uh roger might know the answer to
about couple of distributions
find a couple of find couple of
parameters
this is not this is absolutely not the
topic of this meeting but but what is
the answer to whether we have a thing
for find couple of parameters why isn't
that fine well i don't know let's
estimate a distribution it works so a
copula distribution
is a what we call a derived distribution
it uses it's it's a distribution as a
function of other distributions
and uh
you can definitely identify you know
estimate those parameters so estimated
distribution will
well very good okay so person whose
name looks to be in
a character set i do not recognize
uh i'm not thinking it might be see now
now this is where this is where we also
get to use technology let's just see
um
oh my gosh
let's see now we say
character name
tie okay oh my god
there all right well anyway so the
answer
um
is that
estimated distribution to find just and
find distribution parameters those are
two
two interfaces to the same functionality
basically one gives the full object back
and the other one gives the parameters
back
okay
good stuff all right i think we just uh
spent time here what's that we we still
have two things from the video
oh no
oh no
i i i
there's one more thing
oh no
there's one more thing and one more
thing
all right i
i think what yes
thank you i think what we expected to be
a longer discussion might actually not
be very long if you want to open graphic
store video and look at some of the
examples oh yeah there's no way we're
going to get graphics tools okay but
what you can do at the top is one one
very quick thing at the top though yes
which is playback settings i don't think
is going to be super controversial
that's exactly what you asked for
stephen that the video object should
know its state
and that is the state
question how does that relate to how
animate knows its state
it needs to be saved in the input form
right so that's that will be the way to
save it in the input file but hold on a
second doesn't animate have a way okay
doesn't doesn't i thought animate had a
way to save its state as well
do you understand what i'm saying yeah
let me just uh lock it up
i mean to save anything it needs to be
stored somewhere of course of course of
course of course
animation
animation running
so okay so what determines
if i store an animation in a file what
determines whether it's slider will be
at the origin or not
so
that seems to be
it produces a manipulate right and the
manipulate has a way of stirring the
starting value
for that parameter
so you have instead of parameter min max
you have
list of list per meter comma starting
point comma main
max
so sorry what's the basic option name
for manipulate the this is not an option
this is the the
second argument to manipulate
oh i see i say i see yeah okay right i
know that that's the initial setting but
then then it kind of sort of states that
that's that's what does store the state
it does store it it stores it but but it
stores it associated with the variable
but how does animate do that because
animate doesn't have an animator doesn't
have that does it animate is just to
manipulate right okay somebody's got to
report these bugs this is showing up all
the time
if you if you evaluate the first one
move this slider and then at the input
firm you'll see how that manipulate that
uses the initial setting to preserve the
state
okay fine so that's how it's preserving
the state
and is there anything else like an
animated image how does it preserve the
state uh
i am not sure that does but if it would
it would be exactly the same thing or
dynamic geographics
it needs to be stored somewhere in the
firm be it right but dynamic module is a
typical way to store stuff
how does dynamic geographic store it
i do not know
um
hmm
okay so this is
storing the state of the interactive
player
if that player was an in-notebook player
correct right if it's not a notebook
player you can't store anything you know
we have no idea what happened correct
and the option would be completely
ignored if if you send it to some weird
thing in that case
well but but presumably when you bring
up the external uh player
the external player will also respect
the value of this option is that a true
statement i i don't think so because we
don't have control over what this system
is that obvious
it's obvious that the is that obvious
that the thing with which we call the
system can't contain an encoded version
of where the initial i'm sure like like
a you know a standard youtube video you
can absolutely give a url yeah justifies
where
in the video to show
but we do not know what system player
the user has installed on on the on the
machine okay so so it's hopeless we
might be able to look at i don't know uh
one per platform the most popular one on
each platform i mean i would bet vlc
would be very malleable in this case but
in general uh but i i've not be able to
make any assumptions
okay i i don't think it's gonna i mean
let people use if our in notebook player
works that's what people should be using
um
how is it setting playback setting how
is it storing playback settings
it will be an association yeah um
and yeah the left page should be there
okay
by the way an answer to geographic it
stores it into geo range so you
i mean it's i don't think it's there in
the original input form but there's a
dynamic module variable and then if you
um but if i save the notebook
i got it right but if i export
that dynamic geographics what happens
uh well i suppose it depends on how you
export it but um
as far as where when
you imported an image it would be just
that or if it's vector graph i mean
yeah okay fair enough fair enough
there's nothing else
okay i mean save the look if i save the
right if you save the notebook it'll be
there because it's in a dynamic module
variable right so if i and if i save
that that output cell it will i mean you
know the expression for that output it
will also be there
right
okay hold on so
what's happening here is the video
player
which is in the in in the output cell
is being changed by having its playback
settings changed is that correct yes it
doesn't modify the object the output
cell right it will
is is not if you have a variable the
video's turning a variable v and you
output it
and you modify it that will be a new a
different instance
because you're changing the copy down
it doesn't
there's no duplication of files it uses
the same file
so it's a very effective in the notebook
does it copy a new does it make a new
cell when you do that it doesn't does it
no
i think what happens it detaches from
the input cell on the top
okay fine
and then but then that expression has
different playback settings correct
seems okay i i guess i'm okay with the
name
what about for audio are we gonna do the
same thing though
uh well i mean it makes sense that if we
can do it for one we can do it off for
the other ones but i
i i would be more wary about touching
audio for this release but definitely
understand that can be done
um
i mean once we once we make sure that we
have this wired down and
because this will be a breaking uh
change right in the input form of video
so if you get one from the future it
will not work in the past
so to speak
the opposite
will not be true we can take one but we
ignore
but won't we don't we already ignore
options we don't recognize
no we jack we we failed the video
constructor right
yeah
okay so what will this do so you're
saying a version 13 video will now fail
in version 12. yes but we didn't have we
didn't have an in notebook
display in version 12 anyway
yeah but also not necessarily
yes that is correct
so is there any artifact
which
would have worked
which would now work and will now will
in the future fail i mean which will
fail in version 13.
no everything produced in previous
version will be accepted and working in
13.
but there's no way you could take
something from 13 and put it in 12 right
now
you couldn't do that there's nothing to
do with that
yeah no agree this this is just
yes
that is correct
okay well so we do have to think for a
second about
future options
i mean i i don't think we should fail if
i think what we should do because we
have to future proof against other
options
we should simply say ignoring option
blah blah blah as a message
but that is contrary to what like most
of the at least in the
signal and audio and video code base
if you
pass a function a wrong option to a
function
it will fail
in return i don't think it's the right
thing for this future for proofing
reason
right i mean graphics ignores unknown
options
right if you give it an invalid option
right a known option but an invalid
setting then you'll get pinking
but if you give it
an unknown option it will just happily
ignore it
i think you need to think carefully
about this because i think we need to
future proof it and i think giving a
message but still doing you know
ignoring it with a message seems like
the right compromise
and i guess this can all of the
functions in our code base at least
produce this unevaluated return an error
message
from system private arguments so if it
means just a change in that function
assuming that that is an acceptable
thing okay
okay uh comment from rbs on our live
stream recommending
old school file formats
um
from what's what's it
reading the header of executable data
files
dozens of 3d graphics formats that we
should support i i thought we had done
other than some ridiculous
you know 8-bit video game formats which
i just don't think are worth right now
the effort to support
i thought we were doing a pretty
comprehensive job or is that not the
case
charlie can you comment on that
i don't know about 3d graphics
specifically
um
really haven't done a full study of what
could we support that we don't support
all right well anyway this is just a
live stream i think there's some newer
ones that we that we eager to support
i think for the older ones they're
pretty obscure i don't i'm not aware of
anything that's of significance
look for our virtual machines project
we're supporting
lots of history we'll see how that works
out
um okay all right let's wrap here we got
another live stream coming up in a few
minutes here hold on okay so
what should we do with graphics tour
i told you it needs its own custom
meeting and we don't have the right
people yeah okay fine so i mean i'm
happy to do the meeting but i'm not
going to yeah no no i just want i just
asked a question so so then can i just
confirm really quick were there any
other things here that require this to
get a part six no
okay no we're done thank you very much
and good work everybody
okay on to graphs and geometry and so on